This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you hear these footsteps you can get some idea about who is walking towards you. It's probably a woman that doesn't have to be. She could be a supermodel, a CEO, a drag queen, a bridesmaid, just to name a few. As a fashion object and symbol the high heel is weighted with meaning. It is also weighted with the wearer's entire body weight. The high heeled shoe might be one of the only designs that is physically painful and yet somehow persists. Every truffleman doesn't tend to wear heels.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你听到这些脚步声，你大概能猜出是谁在向你走来。那很可能是一位女性，但也不一定。她可能是超级名模、首席执行官、变装皇后、伴娘，等等。作为一种时尚单品和符号，高跟鞋承载着深刻的含义。它同时也承载着穿着者全身的重量。高跟鞋可能是唯一一种在生理上让人痛苦，却又以某种方式延续至今的设计。并不是每个特鲁布尔曼（Truffleman）都喜欢穿高跟鞋。
I really like the way heels look and I've tried wearing them, but I just cannot do it. So I talk to someone who actually wears them every day. And I have a standing desk. So I'm even a bigger dummy, right? Like, I'm in these heels all day and standing. And when Audi does her job, you can't even tell she's doing it in heels. This is all things considered from NPR News. I'm Adi Cornish. Believe it or not, we, Radio Folk, actually bother to get dressed. Sometimes. For Adi Cornish, like a lot of professionals, high heels are strictly for the office.
我真的很喜欢高跟鞋的样子，也尝试过穿它们，但我实在穿不了。所以我采访了一位每天都穿高跟鞋的人。我有一个站立式办公桌。所以我更像个傻瓜，对吧？我整天穿着高跟鞋站着。当奥迪（Audi）工作时，你甚至看不出她穿着高跟鞋。这里是NPR新闻的《综述》（All Things Considered）。我是阿迪·科尼什（Adi Cornish）。信不信由你，我们这些广播人其实也会费心打扮。偶尔会。对于阿迪·科尼什来说，像许多专业人士一样，高跟鞋是办公室的标配。
Commuting to work, it's flats, after work, back and flats. Because it is impossible, I feel like, to find a shoe that is a high heel that's really gorgeous and Fundamentally comfortable. She's tried high heels that claim to use comfort technology But it's like a three and a half inch four inch pump like it's only gonna be so comfortable They're shoes that are wearable and I can wear them for hours But I wouldn't call it comfortable. It is just it's just possible And she does not like to complain. You do it to yourself, right? So it's dumb to walk around being like, these heels hurt because that's basically like saying,
通勤时穿平底鞋，下班后换回平底鞋。因为我觉得，要找到一双既华丽又从根本上舒适的高跟鞋是不可能的。她试过那些声称采用了舒适技术的高跟鞋，但那毕竟是三英寸半到四英寸的细高跟，舒适度终究有限。它们是可以穿的，我能穿上几个小时，但我不会称之为舒适。这只是……只是勉强可行。而且她不喜欢抱怨。这是你自己选择的，对吧？所以到处抱怨“这些高跟鞋真疼”是很愚蠢的，因为这基本上等于在说，
I failed at this look. But people have been failing at this look for a very long time. I can't tell when the heel was actually invented. I think that history is long buried and dates back centuries and centuries and centuries in the Near East. Elizabeth Samoahak curates a very specialized museum in Toronto. I'm Elizabeth Samoahak and I'm the senior curator at the Bada Shee Museum. I've got to ask, why isn't it the Shusium? I don't know. You were the first to ask me that question. The collection at the Badashim Museum, or Shusium, includes a lot of different kinds of footwear,
我没能驾驭好这个造型。但人们在驾驭这个造型上已经失败了很久。我无法确定高跟鞋究竟是什么时候发明的。我认为那段历史早已被埋没，可以追溯到近东地区几个世纪甚至更久以前。伊丽莎白·塞梅尔哈克（Elizabeth Semmelhack）在多伦多管理着一家非常专业的博物馆。我是伊丽莎白·塞梅尔哈克，我是巴塔鞋履博物馆（Bata Shoe Museum）的资深策展人。我得问问，为什么不叫“鞋履博物馆”（Shusium）？我不知道。你是第一个问我这个问题的人。巴塔鞋履博物馆，或者说“鞋履博物馆”的藏品包括各种各样的鞋类，
but high heels are the focus of Elizabeth Simulhac's research and the subject of her book, Heights of Fashion, a history of the elevated shoe. And that history, as it turns out, started with men. Many horseback riding cultures wore heels on their boots and on their shoes for riding. Heels help you stay in the stirrups, which is why cowboy boots have heels.
但高跟鞋是伊丽莎白·塞梅尔哈克研究的重点，也是她那本《时尚高度：高跟鞋的历史》（Heights of Fashion: A History of the Elevated Shoe）的主题。事实证明，这段历史始于男性。许多骑马文化在靴子和鞋子上都加了鞋跟，以便骑行。鞋跟能帮助你稳在马镫里，这就是为什么牛仔靴会有鞋跟。
As early as the 10th century, the Persian cavalry was wearing inch high, high heels. And Persia had a really big, really talented, mounted military, so this spread the trend. And so European men have heels added to their riding boots. It's associated with upper-class practice because having horses, keeping horses, you know, it's like having a sports car. And so it seems that from there, men wore it first, within short order, upper class women added heels to their own outfits, and then heels become a form of upper and
早在10世纪，波斯骑兵就开始穿一英寸高的高跟鞋了。波斯拥有一支规模庞大、才华横溢的骑兵部队，因此这一趋势得以传播。于是，欧洲男性也在他们的骑行靴上加了鞋跟。这与上层阶级的习俗有关，因为拥有马匹、饲养马匹，就像现在拥有跑车一样。因此，看起来是男性先穿了高跟鞋，不久之后，上层阶级女性也将高跟鞋加入了自己的装束，随后高跟鞋成为17世纪上层和
middle class dress throughout the 17th century. But it really wasn't yet a strong signifier of gender. In all those paintings of Louis XIV and his little kitten heels, he's dressing like the pillar of normative aristocratic masculinity he is. Nothing of feminine about him, at the time. But then heels started to get gendered in their designs. Men's heels grew broad and sturdy, and women became tapered and decorative. Finally men deemed them impractical, and in the 18th century the high heel is strictly a lady shoe. And something really interesting happens at the end of the 18th century, the high heel is strictly a lady shoe. And something really interesting happens
中产阶级的服饰。但它当时还不是一个强烈的性别标志。在所有路易十四和他那些小猫跟鞋的画像中，他穿着打扮正如他所代表的贵族男性气质的支柱。当时他身上没有任何女性化的东西。但后来，高跟鞋的设计开始有了性别区分。男鞋的鞋跟变得宽大结实，女鞋则变得尖细且具有装饰性。最终，男性认为它们不切实际，到了18世纪，高跟鞋成了女性的专属鞋履。而在18世纪末发生了一件非常有趣的事情，高跟鞋成了女性的专属鞋履。而在18世纪末发生了一件非常有趣的事情，
at the end of the 18th century, which is the French Revolution. And when the French Revolution happens, high heels, although they were very much associated with femininity, they were also very much associated with aristocratic femininity. Post-French Revolution, aristocracy and fribality are out of vogue.
那就是法国大革命。当法国大革命发生时，高跟鞋虽然与女性气质紧密相连，但也与贵族女性气质紧密相连。法国大革命后，贵族气息和浮华不再流行。
And then heels stay out of style for a really, really long time, until, and the Sasemohax theory, the invention of the camera. Because with photography came pornography, and with the rise of pornography came the rise of the heel. Pornography embraced high thin heels before a fashion did, because heels work great when you don't have to move and you're just posing for a few minutes. It's around this time when heels become sex-charged.
此后，高跟鞋沉寂了很长一段时间，直到——按照塞梅尔哈克的理论——相机的发明。因为摄影带来了色情作品，而色情作品的兴起带来了高跟鞋的兴起。色情业比时尚界更早拥抱了高细跟，因为当你不需要走动，只是摆姿势几分钟时，高跟鞋的效果非常好。正是在这个时候，高跟鞋开始被赋予了性色彩。
The pin-ups that are in men's barracks during World War II almost always have high heels on them. When the war is over and the men return home, that is when the stiletto is invented because the stiletto brings fashion into alignment with men's erotic cut. As heels made their way out of photography and onto the street and into the office, there arose the engineering challenge of trying to make this fundamentally uncomfortable thing, comfortable. I think the physics of putting the weight of a woman's body basically on the balls of her feet is
二战期间男兵营里的海报女郎几乎都穿着高跟鞋。战争结束后，男人们回到家乡，细高跟鞋（stiletto）便应运而生，因为它将时尚与男性的色情视角统一了起来。随着高跟鞋从摄影领域走向街头和办公室，试图让这种本质上不舒服的东西变得舒适，就成了一个工程挑战。我认为，将女性身体的重量基本压在脚掌上的物理原理是
You know, that's a lot of pressure to try to mitigate. So people try to find ways around the design There are foldable flat shoes that you can take with you and you just can't take the pain of a high heel anymore But if you want to go the whole nine yards or nine hours in pumps, YouTube is full of hacks and tips and tricks. Put the heel liner in and it will prevent your shoe from like flopping off. You know what I mean? Magyver type fixes for the shoe. All you need is felt and glue stick and glue
你知道，要减轻这种压力非常困难。所以人们试图寻找绕过这种设计的方法。有可以随身携带的折叠平底鞋，因为你实在无法再忍受高跟鞋的痛苦了。但如果你想在穿高跟鞋时坚持到底，或者坚持九个小时，YouTube上到处都是窍门和技巧。塞进鞋垫，它能防止你的鞋子掉跟。你懂我的意思吗？像马盖先（MacGyver）那样的鞋子修复法。你只需要毛毡、胶棒和胶水，
and some scissors and aglut gun. Remember guys do not burn yourself. Maggyver type fixes for the foot. All you have to do is take together your third and your fourth toe. I promise this work. Classes and tutorials for learning how to walk in heels. Practice, practice, practice. And I don't want you girls to be afraid about going up and down the stairs and heels.
还有一把剪刀和一把热熔胶枪。记住，伙计们，别烫伤自己。像马盖先那样的足部修复法。你所要做的就是把你的第三个脚趾和第四个脚趾绑在一起。我保证这招管用。还有学习如何穿高跟鞋走路的课程和教程。练习，练习，再练习。我不希望你们这些女孩害怕穿着高跟鞋上下楼梯。
It's actually fairly easy. In the most extreme cases, people have gotten surgeries to shorten their pinky toes, dead in their nerves, or shoot Botox into their feet, all to circumvent the pain of the high heel. You start to feel it at the very bottom of your foot. The baller foot has all the nerves. And then you'll start to rub on your heels and rub on the sides and then suddenly you step down and it's gonna be a shooting stabbing pain and after that pain you'll go numb. Meet the twins. I'm Emily Liang. I'm three minutes older. I'm Jessica Liang.
这其实相当容易。在最极端的情况下，人们甚至会通过手术缩短小脚趾、切断神经，或者往脚里注射肉毒杆菌，所有这些都是为了规避高跟鞋带来的痛苦。你开始在脚底感觉到它。前脚掌布满了神经。然后你会开始摩擦脚后跟和两侧，突然间你踩下去，就会感到一阵刺痛，在那阵疼痛之后，你的脚就会麻木。来认识一下这对双胞胎。我是艾米丽·梁（Emily Liang）。我大三分钟。我是杰西卡·梁（Jessica Liang）。
We have a vintage inspired modern comfort wedding shoe line. So that people who are getting married don't have numb feet or aching legs or crooked posture or nerve damage. Because it's not just your foot pain, it's your ankle pain, it shortens your calves, it ruins your posture. Not to mention bunions and hammer toe and haggling's deformity. Google these if you want to,
我们有一个复古风格的现代舒适婚鞋系列。这样结婚的人就不会脚麻、腿酸、姿势扭曲或神经受损。因为这不仅仅是脚痛，还会导致脚踝疼痛，缩短小腿肌肉，破坏你的姿势。更不用说拇囊炎、锤状趾和哈格伦德畸形（Haglund's deformity）了。如果你想了解，可以去谷歌搜索这些，
but do not click image search. Some things you just can unsee. The Leung twins designed hacks into the shoe and borrowed elements from other kinds of footwear. When we actually first started we frankenstined the most comfortable aspects of different shoes. They started with the toe box, which is basically the very front of the shoe, where the toes are. They took the toe box from a salsa dancer's high heel, which tends to be roomier. Just to give your foot enough room to be able to
但千万别点图片搜索。有些东西一旦看到就无法忘记。梁氏双胞胎在鞋子里设计了巧妙的解决方案，并借鉴了其他鞋类的元素。当我们刚开始的时候，我们把不同鞋子中最舒适的部分像“科学怪人”一样拼凑在一起。她们从鞋头（toe box）开始，也就是鞋子的最前端，脚趾所在的地方。她们采用了萨尔萨舞高跟鞋的鞋头，因为那里通常更宽敞。只是为了给你的脚留出足够的空间，以便
swell as you're standing, every foot will swell throughout the day. The whole shoe is really padded and cushioned. And like running shoes, they have arch support built right in. They're not stilettos. For balance purposes, the liongs made the heel thick where it meets the foot. But balance purposes, the liongs made the heel thick where it meets the foot.
在你站立时能够肿胀，每只脚在一天中都会肿胀。整双鞋都经过了充分的填充和缓冲。而且像跑鞋一样，它们内置了足弓支撑。它们不是细高跟。为了平衡起见，梁氏姐妹把鞋跟与脚接触的地方做得比较厚。为了平衡起见，梁氏姐妹把鞋跟与脚接触的地方做得比较厚。
But for aesthetics, the sturdy heel tapers to a finer point where it meets the floor. You don't want to look at this shoe and think it's a comfort shoe. Although comfort shoe is relative. We guarantee our shoes are going to be at least an hour more comfortable than all your other shoes. For the liong twins, even the most comfortable high heels still have a time limit. But Martha Davis begs to differ. I don't have that same feeling.
但为了美观，结实的鞋跟在接触地面时会变细。你不会想看着这双鞋觉得它是一双舒适鞋。尽管舒适鞋是相对的。我们保证我们的鞋子至少比你所有的其他鞋子多舒适一个小时。对于梁氏双胞胎来说，即使是最舒适的高跟鞋也有时间限制。但玛莎·戴维斯（Martha Davis）却不这么认为。我没有那种感觉。
I feel I wear these shoes 12 hours a day every day, and I know quite a few women who do the same, and I have never had any problems with them. Although Martha Davis is talking about shoes that she made. My name is Martha Davis, and I'm an industrial designer, and I've been had any problems with them. Although Martha Davis is talking about shoes that she made. My name is Martha Davis, and I'm an industrial designer, and I've been working in the footwear industry for the last eight years. You may be familiar with her industrial design work. Martha Davis designed the round, compact case for the pill. Like the Leung twins, Davis was wearing high heels before she started designing them, and
我觉得我每天穿这些鞋12个小时，我知道不少女性也这样做，我从来没有遇到过任何问题。尽管玛莎·戴维斯谈论的是她自己制作的鞋子。我叫玛莎·戴维斯，我是一名工业设计师，我已经在鞋类行业工作了八年。你可能熟悉她的工业设计作品。玛莎·戴维斯设计了那款圆形的避孕药紧凑盒。像梁氏双胞胎一样，戴维斯在开始设计高跟鞋之前也穿高跟鞋，而且
she couldn't find a high heeled shoe that looked good and didn't cause pain. Davis went to Milan to study a process of shoe making called the Lunati method, which emphasizes measurement and proportionality, and her takeaway is this. A heel can be really successful as long as the shoe fits properly, so it's not a question of the height, it's a question of the fit. And there's one critical point where the fit really matters. And it's called the calzata. Calzata. Calzata. Calzata.
她找不到一双既好看又不会引起疼痛的高跟鞋。戴维斯去了米兰学习一种名为“卢纳蒂方法”（Lunati method）的制鞋工艺，该方法强调测量和比例，她的结论是：只要鞋子合脚，鞋跟就能非常成功，所以这不仅仅是高度的问题，而是合脚的问题。有一个关键点，合脚性非常重要。它被称为“calzata”。Calzata。Calzata。Calzata。
They call it the fitting point. That's the number one critical spot. If you look down at your feet, it's kind of right before your foot becomes your toes. So in terms of girth, it's the widest part of your foot. You have to secure that spot and make sure it's not too loose or too tight. The calzada is not the only significant spot. The toe box could be too shallow and the pitch of the heel could be too steep or not steep enough. There are a number of factors,
他们称之为“合脚点”。这是最重要的关键点。如果你低头看你的脚，它就在你的脚变成脚趾之前的位置。所以就周长而言，它是你脚最宽的部分。你必须固定住那个点，确保它既不太松也不太紧。Calzata并不是唯一重要的点。鞋头可能太浅，鞋跟的坡度可能太陡或不够陡。有很多因素，
but it's most important to keep the calzada in proportion to the other numbers for comfort and security. The lunati method allows Martha to play around with sculptural forms and hard materials, like steel and gnarled wood, with hardly any padding. Though she keeps her shoes relatively low. But a quote unquote low heel is nothing to scoff at. I wore around three inch heels this week just to try it, and my feet are killing me. So why bother?
但为了舒适和稳固，保持Calzata与其他尺寸的比例最为重要。卢纳蒂方法让玛莎能够尝试雕塑般的造型和坚硬的材料，如钢和多节的木头，几乎不需要任何填充物。尽管她保持鞋跟相对较低。但所谓的“低跟”也不容小觑。我这周试着穿了大约三英寸的高跟鞋，我的脚快疼死了。那么为什么要自找麻烦呢？
Ah, well it's complicated. I asked Adi Cornish this question too. The same twinge that makes me feel awkward about discussing high heals is the same thing that makes me think like, why do I shave my legs? You know what I mean? It's like my whole feminism 101 collegiate self, like railing at me from the past being like you've sold out in every way possible. But there is something to be said for a well-made high heels shoe that kind of makes your calf look amazing and puts that like inappropriate probably sexy
啊，这很复杂。我也问过阿迪·科尼什这个问题。那种让我对讨论高跟鞋感到尴尬的刺痛感，和让我思考“我为什么要刮腿毛？”的感觉是一样的。你知道我的意思吗？就像我大学时代的女权主义启蒙自我，在过去对我咆哮，说我在各个方面都出卖了自己。但一双做工精良的高跟鞋确实有其可取之处，它能让你的小腿看起来很棒，并带来那种不恰当的、可能很性感的
arch in your back. I like that feeling. The heel is so tied up in webs of gender and sex and power. Look, I can't speak for everyone, but when it comes to the appeal of the heel, it's actually not very complex psychology. Heels affect the way you move through the world. They change your walk. They make you push your shoulders back, hold your head up and swing your hips.
背部曲线。我喜欢那种感觉。高跟鞋与性别、性和权力的网络紧密相连。听着，我不能代表所有人，但说到高跟鞋的吸引力，其实心理学并不复杂。高跟鞋影响了你在世界中行走的方式。它们改变了你的步态。它们让你挺胸抬头，摆动臀部。
They make you taller. But it's not really about that. I mean, I'm already pretty tall. Actually in general, height is not as big a factor as you would think. People will often say to me, well, women wear high heels today because they want to be as tall as men. Elizabeth's a little hot again. I counter with that and I say, I do understand that reasoning, but there are many, many, many men who would equally benefit from increased height. And so why are they ignoring the potential power of the high heel?
它们让你更高。但这并不是重点。我的意思是，我已经很高了。事实上，总的来说，身高并不是你想象中那么大的因素。人们经常对我说，嗯，女性今天穿高跟鞋是因为她们想和男人一样高。伊丽莎白又来了。我反驳说，我理解那种推理，但有很多很多男性同样会从身高增加中受益。那么为什么他们忽视了高跟鞋的潜在力量呢？
But it wasn't too long ago when heels for guys were kind of cool. Think of the opening scene of Saturday Night Fever. John Travolta is walking through the streets of New York and he's strutting around in high heel boots. The camera is focused on his shoes. It puts an undeniable swagger in his step. Men tried high heels in the 70s, and why didn't it stick? To condense Elizabeth Semmelhack's research, men's heels in the 70s were too tied up in
但不久前，男士穿高跟鞋还挺酷的。想想《周末夜狂热》（Saturday Night Fever）的开场镜头。约翰·特拉沃尔塔（John Travolta）走在纽约的街道上，穿着高跟靴大摇大摆。镜头聚焦在他的鞋子上。这让他的步伐有一种不可否认的傲慢。男人们在70年代尝试过高跟鞋，为什么没能坚持下来？总结伊丽莎白·塞梅尔哈克的观点，70年代男士高跟鞋与
subculture. The exoticizing elements kept it on the fringe. And so the men's chunky platform went out of style when power dressing of the 1980s came along. Men were in suits and ties, women were in suits and heels, and they still are. The high heel could come to mean simply professional power, or it could come to be that female professionals are the new power brokers. but then I would not be surprised if that happens that men will be as eager to wear high heels as women.
亚文化联系太紧密了。异国情调的元素使其处于边缘地位。因此，当1980年代的权力着装（power dressing）出现时，男士厚底鞋就过时了。男人们穿西装打领带，女人们穿西装配高跟鞋，而且现在依然如此。高跟鞋可能仅仅意味着职业权力，或者它可能意味着女性专业人士是新的权力掮客。但如果真的发生了这种情况，我一点也不会惊讶，因为男人们会像女性一样渴望穿高跟鞋。
Okay, but only if they can design comfortable ones. 99% invisible was produced this week by Avery Troubleman with Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of ArcSide. We walk around with paint cans, strutting, took the big sheets. And beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can keep up with this show and all the people make this show on Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr, but your calzada will always be comfortable at 99bi.org. Radio Tapio.
好吧，但前提是他们能设计出舒适的鞋子。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁布尔曼（Avery Troubleman）制作，萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）和我罗曼·马斯共同参与。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在ArcSide办公室制作。我们带着油漆罐走来走去，大摇大摆，拿着大纸张。在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Tumblr上关注这个节目以及所有制作这个节目的人，但你的Calzata在99bi.org上永远会很舒适。广播塔皮奥（Radio Tapio）。
From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。